und was für ein Paukenschlag diese Woche
aus dem
Konrad-Adenauer-Haus es ist wirklich
passiert ich kann es immer noch nicht
fassen die
christlich-demokratische Union CDU hat
ein neues Logo ja ist das schön geworden
ja ja und übrigens eben nicht türkis wie
die ÖVP in Österreich nein diese völlig
neue Farbe nennt sich Cadenabbia blau
ja benannt nach dem Lieblingsort wo
Konrad Adenauer immer Urlaub gemacht hat
ne ein Glück das ist nicht der
Ballermann war muss man sagen wer fragt
da noch nach Thüringen wo die CDU
erstmals mit der AFD ein Gesetz
durchgebracht hat angesichts dieses
coolen neuen Looks und ich sage Ihnen
der Spot dazu der ist ja sogar noch
fresher da sieht man unter anderem
irgendein Unkraut ein CDU-Wähler der
sich vor Frust in die Hand beißt ein
Roboter hat Sex mit einem Menschen da
hat sich eine Rentnerin eingeschliffen
und hier müssen wir mal ganz kurz
anhalten Stopp ne war großes Thema im
Netz richtig gesehen da hat der CDU
Praktikant
statt Reichstag einfach mal den
Präsidenten Palast von Georgien
reingeschnitten
ist doch egal wenn man sagt ja nicht
umsonst tief ist oder Berlin Hauptsache
Italien ja
also äh wir fassen zusammen neue
cdu-farbe neues Logo neuer Reichstag
aber ich sag mal gibt's denn auch eine
inhaltliche Strategie
Strategie ist ganz einfach
CDU pur
geil
außerdem erhältlich in den
Geschmacksrichtungen CDU sweet Lemon
und CDU Zero natürlich ja das war jetzt
so klassischer hohler Marketing sprech
vom Generalsekretär Linnemann aber ich
frage noch mal wofür steht die pure CDU
wo geht die Reise hin nach dem Tabubruch
von Erfurt ja so nenne ich den na klar
wegen eins Komma fünf Prozent weniger
Grund Erwerbsteuer in Thüringen lässt
man sich ausgerechnet von Bernd höcke
helfen ja
gut vielleicht hat die AFD sich da dran
gehängt an der CDU-Antrag aber es war ja
trotzdem vorher klar dass man ihre
Stimmen braucht oder was genau ist da
passiert kann mir das mal irgendwer
möglichst umständlich erklären sie
kommen zur Arbeit haben einen neuen
Drucker mitgebracht den wollen sie jetzt
unbedingt in ihr Büro im vierten Stock
tragen alleine schaffen sie das aber
nicht es kommen diverse Kollegen vorbei
die so um Hilfe bitten die sagen aber
nee so ein Drucker brauchen wir
überhaupt nicht sie wollen den aber
unbedingt da haben dann kommt der
Kollege den sie gar nicht mögen der in
der Kantine immer durch unangenehme
Sprüche auffällt und deshalb schon ein
Gerichtsverfahren am Hals hat und der
sagt klar trage ich den mit den nach
oben würden sie das machen so was
ähnliches hat die CDU in Thüringen
gerade erlebt überhaupt nicht
bernd höcke hat geholfen beim Drucker
tragen wann war das denn
tapfer hat ja länger gedauert als die
Abstimmung von Erfurt und diese
Abstimmung steht natürlich nicht für
einen grundsätzlichen Rechtsruck der CDU
sie war aber auch keine Bagatelle finde
ich klar auf einen Antrag verzichten
wegen der AFD gibt den rechten auch
wieder macht dass die Lämmer liegt auf
der Hand nur sollte man dann als
Friedrich Merz auch auf Sätze verzichten
wie mit der AFD wird es keine
Zusammenarbeit geben weder auf dem Tisch
noch über dem Tisch noch unter dem Tisch
aha geht neben dem Tisch
und was wird jetzt aus seiner berühmten
Mauer
bröckelt die Brandmauer zur AFD die
Brandmauer muss stehen Brandauer
Brandenburg
genau den meine ich Klaus Maria
Brandmauer ja wenn alleine der nicht
enden wollende AFD Jubel seit Erfurt
sollte der CDU schon ein bisschen zu
denken geben egal die Brandmauer steht
wie eine Eins sogar in den CDU
ostverbänden oder Herr März hat gesagt
mit diesen Leuten haben wir nichts zu
tun mit der AFD ist es auch ihr Eindruck
nein überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht wir
reden völlig offen wir arbeiten völlig
offen zusammen mehr haben 0
Brandenburgern
okay Null ist wenig ja ja das passiert
halt wenn man als Parteiführung die
Grünen zum Hauptfeind erklärt klar das
war jetzt natürlich nur eine
Einzelstimme aus grauschwitz wo immer
das sein mag ich würde mal sagen die
Brandmauer ist noch da mit Stacheldraht
und allem top gesichert aber sie ist
wohl nicht mehr besonders hoch ne also
man kommt schon irgendwie rüber wenn man
will ja Andreas Reuter Chef der CDU
Grundwerte Kommission also nicht
irgendwer plädiert diese Woche für CDU
Minderheitsregierung im Osten die dann
auch mal Sachen mit der AFD durchsetzen
top Idee richtig gut die Idee bis man
von der AFD eines Tages ersetzt wird und
übrigens in Erfurt gab es sehr wohl eine
Art Kooperation CDU und AFD haben
nämlich dafür gesorgt dass Punkte von
der Tagesordnung verschwunden sind damit
genug Zeit bleibt für ihre
Grunderwerbsteuer
weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber für
mich geht das schon in die Flirt
Richtung
du sitzt für die CDU im Thüringer
Landtag und fühlst diese Leere wo ist
der hin der Thrill der Kick für den
Augenblick und ständig machen sie dich
buschig die heißen Bad Boys von der AFD
ja es ist verboten mit ihnen zu reden
aber das macht es ja auch irgendwie geil
[Musik]
immer ehrlich was geht es über märz an
was in Erfurt und am Tisch passiert
diskrete politische Affären melde Dich
jetzt anbei
siedelt das Ziel steht für christlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man riecht man richtig Schweißfüße so
natürlich wollen wir alle
unterscheidbare Volksparteien und das
heißt in der Konsequenz für die CDU auch
mal konservative Kante zeigen klar ohne
dabei andere Zielgruppen zu verschrecken
das ist nicht einfach Beispiel von den
Frauen unter 29 können sich gerade nur
sechs Prozent Friedrich Merz als Kanzler
vorstellen da muss er vielleicht mal
angreifen der Friedrich den alten Charme
spielen lassen ja warum nicht ja mal
ausprobieren
im Moment stehen junge Frauen wohl eher
auf seine Kanzler Konkurrenz in der CDU
auf Daniel Günther zum Beispiel diesen
crazy Rebellen von der Küste was der
sich getraut hat nach Erfurth das muss
jetzt auch von unserer Seite aus weiter
klargestellt werden dass das ein
Einzelfall auch gewesen ist der sich so
nicht wiederholen darf das ist eine
Einzelmeinung in der CDU es gibt
niemanden sonst der das teilt auch
öffentlich äh vorgetragen so wie es
gemacht hat so wie er das gemacht hat
der unverschämte Kieler Lümmel
deswegen schreibt er jetzt auch 50 mal
an die Tafel ich darf dem Vorsitzenden
nicht widersprechen ein Ungeheuer
Vorgang über eine eigene Meinung in
der Günther zu Erfurt gesagt hat bis
neulich CDU Konsens ne ein mutiger Mann
aus dem Premium Bundesland
Schleswig-Holstein wo laut einer Umfrage
Achtung
65% der Menschen zu frieden sind mit
ihrer Regierung ist das unfassbar mitten
unter uns leben noch zufriedene deutsche
nach jenseits der üblichen
Schleswig-Holstein bei Hauke Matschke
einem
x-beliebigen Schleswig-Holsteiner
Passanten Hauke was ist euer Geheimnis
ja also viel Platz würde ich mal meinen
nicht
ja wir haben hier nur 187 Einwohner pro
Quadratkilometer die Kollegen hinter mir
gar nicht mitgerechnet
du gehst ja halt insgesamt weniger auf
den Sack und wenn mich einer unbedingt
besuchen will dann sehe ich den schon
drei Tage vorher kommen das ist ein
riesen bloß ne deswegen Platz 1 im
sogenannten glücksradlas zum glücklich
seid ist es nämlich ganz entscheidend
dass du so wenig andere Leute triffst
wie möglich ne verstehe und vor lauter
Glück habt ihr dann sogar die AFD aus
dem Landtag gewählt als einziges
deutsches Flächenland ja klar ja
Zufriedenheit und
aktioniert und jetzt funktioniert
schwarz grün wir Schleswig-Holsteiner
mögen und ich weiß dass ich schwer zu
begreifen für euch tschüss bei den Rest
Deutschland Regierung die
zusammenarbeiten statt zu streiten so
jetzt kommst du hör doch auf in der
Regierung zusammenarbeiten ihr spinnt
doch da oben wirklich ja logisch immer
schön ruhig durch die teamatmen und
Probleme wegarbeiten was denn sonst
streiken ist Emotionen und an Emotionen
glauben wir hier nicht vor allem aber
haben wir einen Ministerpräsidenten der
sich nichts scheißt und wenn Daniel der
steht in den norddeutsche Eiche bei
Windstärke 12 immer authentisch und
immer Staatsmann
[Applaus]
und so weiter hier 69% von uns sind
zufrieden mit seiner Arbeit
auf Friesennerz
ist das jetzt also das CDU Duell der
nächsten Monate März gegen Günther Duell
was denn für Duell hör mir auf mit Mercy
dieser Sauerländer leicht Matrose der
weiß ja nicht mal wie eine Brandauer
funktioniert und deswegen finde ich muss
man doch einfach als konservativer
schlicht und ergreifend den Satz sagen
ich bilde keine Mehrheiten mit
Extremisten und wenn ich darauf
angewiesen bin dann weiß ich in dem
Augenblick ich kann meine Hand nicht
dafür heben
ja schreibt das mit mehr zu einer
klubschi da ja man nennt das Prinzipien
unser Daniel der lässt sich gar nichts
sagen der hat massive Eier in der Welt
wir sind Holsteiner Zuchtbulle wie schön
also ganz Deutschland soll von euch
lernen ja von wem denn sonst könnte er
verkanzler dann war es das für die AFD
ich fordere in die Gründung der
Bundesrepublik Schleswig Deutschland
vorne schwarz rot gold mit zwei
gekreuzen und das hier ist natürlich die
neue Hymne Männer
heiß leider
Matthias Matschke vielen Dank
Schleswig-Holstein so liebe Zuschauer
heute keine Ahnung ob sie es mitbekommen
haben heute hat im Bundestag die Union
die Ampel eingeladen bei einem
deutschland-pakt für Migration
mitzumachen bisschen viel Deutschland
packte in letzter Zeit aber in der Sache
natürlich ein wichtiges Anliegen wir
stecken mitten in einer migrationskrise
und die Ampel Macht zu wenig muss man so
sagen ja nächster flüchtlingsgipfel erst
im November das riecht leider nach
gelebter Ratlosigkeit in den ersten 8
Monaten des Jahres wurden in Deutschland
schon mehr als 200.000 Asylanträge
gestellt das sind
77% mehr als im Vorjahr Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine wie immer natürlich nicht
mitgerechnet und auch wenn es bei dem
Thema keine schnellen oder einfachen
Lösungen gibt den Kommunen gut zuhören
sollte man schon
wir haben jetzt dieses Grundstück dass
wir noch zur Verfügung stellen können
das sind für 100 Flüchtlinge alle 14
Tage kommt der Bus mit 50 da kann man
sich ausrechnen wie lange das hält
gibt es doch gar nicht bei dem Fahren
noch Busse
auf dem Land das kann doch nicht wahr
sein ja solchen Kommunen die gerade ist
mit Geld allein nicht geholfen über mehr
sichere Herkunftsländer Maghreb-Staaten
und Indien muss man zumindest mal reden
Grüße an die Grünen und angesichts der
neuen Fluchtroute Moskau Minsk
Deutschland vielen Dank dafür Putin auch
über stationäre Grenzkontrollen im Osten
ja die migrationskrise lässt sich am
Ende nur europäisch lösen natürlich aber
ich sag mal von einer deutschen
Innenministerin muss trotzdem mehr
kommen als das hier doch wir werden uns
gemeinsam jetzt auf den Weg machen ein
gemeinsamer Aktionsplan auf den Weg zu
bringen eine Task Force mit den
Nachbarländern haben dazu jetzt auch
eine operative Analyse zentrale
eingesetzt was konkret das ist eine
operative Analyseeinheit bei der
Bundespolizei
ich brauche mehr Details ja ich auch ich
auch so eine
analyse-task Force plant einen
Aktionsplan wie wir das operativ lösen
cool ja derweil bröckelt das Vertrauen
in die Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates es
fehlen Wohnung Kitaplätze Lehrer kurz
alle Zutaten für gelungene Integration
so wie jetzt kann es jedenfalls nicht
weitergehen im Mittelmeer sterben weiter
Menschen und Schleuser entscheiden wer
hier hin darf wie wäre es denn mal mit
einem gerechten Verteilungsschlüssel in
der EU
bester Witz des Tages oh Verteilung
Schlüssel ja er hört auch der erhoffte
neue Asylkompromiss der EU hängt ja im
Kern leider ab von Lastenverteilung
innerhalb Europas wo sich mehrere
Staaten aber bekanntlich komplett
verweigern Ungarn natürlich wissen sie
aber auch Polen regiert von der
piss-partei
ich sag den Namen einfach zu gerne
die Regierung von Recht und
Gerechtigkeit war von Anfang an gegen
die Zwangsumsiedlung illegaler
Einwanderer wir sagen nein zur illegalen
Einwanderung
eben nein ganz genau die pisspartei sagt
illegale Einwanderer sollen sich
gefälligst verpissen ne sie sind nicht
erwünscht in Polen also es sei denn wie
sich jetzt gerade rausgestellt hat sie
zahlen da Eintritt
ausgerechnet Polen das jegliche
Zusammenarbeit in Migrationsfragen
verweigert soll möglicherweise mehrere
hunderttausend Arbeitsvisa gegen Cache
in Afrika und Asien verkauft haben jo
polnisches Arbeitsvisum was letzte Preis
ärgerliche Enthüllung so kurz vor der
Wahl in Polen
ärgerlich Korruption stellt sich raus
bei denen fehlen wohl doch Arbeitskräfte
komisch nur weil meine fremdenfeindliche
Stimmung schüren über Jahre kommt doch
irgendwann keiner mehr zum Arbeiten
dahin wer hätte das ahnen können
Schengen Raum Visa der Verkauf sind im
polnischen QVC sagt das nicht aber du
willst unbedingt in die EU dann kauf dir
auf keinen Fall diesen beschissenen
Staubsauger sondern ein frisches
polnisches Arbeitsvisum bei der piss
Partei für ein kleines Vermögen drucken
wir dir den Fisch aus da kennen wir
nicht und dann macht die Kasse vom
katschinski
schönsky
jetzt bestellen unter 090 EU
ach ja
die Heuchler von der pisspartei ja aber
ich finde es ja immer schön wenn
unhaltbare Versprechung von Populisten
verpuffen Ursula von der Leyen bleibt
übrigens derweil nichts anderes als
immer wieder an bestimmte EU-Staaten zu
appellieren doch auch mal Menschen
aufzunehmen Appelle er ist nicht drin ja
interessiert die Staaten aber nicht
dublin ist offiziell tot wir müssen das
Thema Asyl völlig neu denken so wie der
Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus er
schlägt vor Asylverfahren in wohlgemerkt
sicheren afrikanischen Drittstaaten wie
Senegal oder woanders durchzuführen das
Plus Kontingente für legale Einwanderung
könnte vielleicht langfristig die Lösung
sein langfristig ja
oder man denkt einfach immer nur bis zur
nächsten Wahl weil es intellektuell für
mehr nicht reicht Markus Söder fordert
die große Wände in der deutschen
Flüchtlingspolitik 200.000 Migranten pro
Jahr mehr geht nicht sagte der
bayerische Ministerpräsident statt
Obergrenze nennt er das
Integrationsgrenze
viel besser ja die Obergrenze heißt
jetzt Integrationsgrenze das ist wohl
das dümmste Rebranding seit sich neulich
Super RTL umbenannt hat in RTL super ja
es wird davon aber nicht super meine
Damen und Herren und hier Obergrenze
lieber Herr Söder funktioniert heute
genauso wenig wie damals unter Seehofer
wie denn auch meine wie soll das gehen
in der Praxis steht dann irgendwann im
Juni Juli wenn genau der 200 000 da ist
einer an der Grenze und ruft wie vor
einem überfüllten Club so sorry Leute
wir sind voll für dieses Jahr und alles
so echt auch Männer aber machst du nix
ja dann kommt man nächstes Jahr wieder
schön mit Öl bis dann die Wanski
was für ein Quatsch und der Söder diese
gelernte ich AG weiß das ja selber er
ist aber im Wahlkampfmodus deswegen
steht er das vor Wahlkampf in Bayern
muss jetzt quasi minütlich damit rechnen
dass der Mann einen mit irgendeinem
Quatsch belästigt
hallo Oliver danke dass du so
unterstützt hier kannst du mal sehen wie
Bayern auch in der Zukunft an der Spitze
in Deutschland bleibt
interessiert mich einen Scheiß
ich wohne da gar nicht das hat er
ernsthaft für 600 verschiedene Vornamen
aufgezeichnet ja wirklich ich fürchte so
wird das jetzt noch zwei Wochen
weitergehen bis zur Bayernwahl deshalb
schalten wir mal live in die
csu-wahlkampfzentrale zu Tatjana Gertz
hat auf Social Media forgets ist ihr
Chef möglicherweise nervös
ah quatsche andere Parteien werden frohe
über unsere Zahlen ich behaupte wir
knacken bald wieder die 40% und jedes
neue Foto von Markus peitscht die CSU
weiter nach oben schneller Posten Leute
wir brauchen viel mehr Fotos von Söder
so toll machst du das Markus Jack face
sexy stimmt ich habe gelesen ihr geht
pro Jahr rund 180.000 € aus nur für
Söder Bilder was heißt nur ist doch top
angelegt wir haben dafür sogar einen
Fotografen fest angestellt der darf den
ganzen Tag den Markus Knöpfen so ein
Glückspilz geileren Job gibt's doch gar
nicht so aber das hier ist der
eigentliche Trumpf im Wahlkampf Söder
ist da sind Fotos drin auf den Söder
ist mit Backen so was wollen die Leute
sehen es ist der Hammer und wir legen
sogar noch einen drauf hi ich stehe für
das ganz Besonderem hat es noch nie
gegeben ein Wimmelbild nennt man das
eigentlich eine Karte von Bayern wo
verschiedene Protagonisten unsere großen
erfolgreichen Politiker in Bayern dabei
sind bestes Wimmelbild
jetzt Bayern eingefangen hier zum
Beispiel die Untertan jubeln einen
Markus zu der dreimal so groß ist wie
normale Menschen wie in einem Godzilla
Film nur diesmal ist Godzilla halt der
gute
süße aber was ist mit Inhalten was kann
man den Mann noch glauben nach all
seinen Richtungswechseln
interessiert doch keine Sau er ist der
Bayern Papa der Kümmerer mehr braucht
doch gar nicht ich liebe das z.B wenn
ein neuerdings mit dieser
warmen Stimme spricht Bayern ist ein
schönes
Land das anderswo scheiße ich merke zu
nah dran mit der Kamera hier Kevin
Schneider Flex im Chat oder die größte
Wolle aus dem finden
Leute ich lese gerade wir haben im Söder
Kochbuch aus Versehen ein vegetarisches
Gericht abgedruckt irgendwas mit Homos
bescheuert der Markus
Christian
vielen Dank
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten frei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig